hey guys welcome to is this okay where
we talk about things that are happening
in the world wondering if it's okay I'm
nya I'm Becky
I'm deja I'm Morgan I'm queasy yeah I
just realize it's like the view with
like a male guest yeah so today we're
going to talk about how do you separate
the person from their art when the
person can sometimes be problematic in
their life but the work that they've
done is really important or something
that's very valuable what sparked this
discussion was Nate Parker and Birth of
a Nation you have Nate Parker who took
this very important slave revolt story
and so this is a very monumental film
for the black community but seventeen
years ago Nate Parker was caught up in a
rape charge allegation when he was
acquitted of rape essentially yeah 17
years ago I think the reason why the
question or the discussion of today is
more about a broader scope of it is
because with any one of these particular
things you never can know exactly for
sure if the person did it it happened
and this woman is not here anymore
to talk about what happened and she's
not here as a result of that experience
he wouldn't let her about that as well
ain't showing empathy he has not shown
an out of empathy she's like I'm not
gonna say sorry it sucks that that
happened to you or you think that's what
happened to you but I'm not going to
apologize I was leaning towards like
this film is important so like I'll
probably go see it and then I read the
article where he's like I'm not saying
sorry and I was like well now I'm all up
in my feels again I don't know how I
feel okay well I'm gonna go see the
movie for sure
Nate Park is not my friend but always
someone put something on screen that
I think is important to see where do you
personally draw the line between I like
your art but you're a shitty person what
is considered supporting like I know
people who were like I don't turn Chris
Brown off and like the cars on the radio
but I won't buy his album I'm like that
with hip-hop in general like for me I'm
not going to pay for the music I'm not
going to give someone money to take that
money and then oppress me but I mean if
it's there like I'm not gonna throw a
hissy fit about it when we say like
support and artists we probably mean in
some way like buying the song going to a
concert I would continue to purchase
Michael Jackson songs on iTunes I feel a
little weird about that sometimes what
was he convicted he wasn't though
exactly that's the weird part right
that's like because of someone's so much
problem and so much influence but then
again could be someone who did something
so great if you're trying to like debate
with yourself whether or not to like go
see that movie or you know go support
that artist that you know did something
then are you background checking every
artist that you support all situations
are totally different and again I don't
have like the facts on the nape are so
[ __ ] terrible happy for sure
they're an artist that you can think of
that's done something that in your
opinion you still feel okay supporting
their work
I saw the pianist at Polanski did yeah
didn't know Polanski the things he did
right it's like Matt's a horrible person
yeah yeah this was a goal felt and like
here's the thing though for me is that
like it's one thing if you're not aware
of someone doing something terrible and
you've already supported the art that's
one thing but it's hard for me to
consciously know what has happened and
then still feel like I can support that
you want to see some remorse like Roman
Polanski emailed his victim years later
and apologized I wonder how much more
comfortable I would be going to see it
if he just spoke more openly and
sensitively about it I think that
especially as a black person it's really
hard because I feel like at the end of
the day when it's a black figure I'm
forced to choose between my blackness or
like supporting a [ __ ] up thing when
Tyra Banks was like we were all rooting
for you like that's how I felt like
I was like you know like are you kidding
me like we were all rooting for you and
the thing about it is like I was so
ready I was like yes people are excited
about it because it's educational and
it's about black folks who are
unapologetic and that's something that
we need today but then this came up and
I'm like there's no way that I can
support this I felt this way about
straight out of Compton to like you know
I was so here for it especially as
someone who loves hip-hop and then to
find out about all the dr. Dre and the
the women beating things and then the
casting call and I was like I can't I
can't give you my money because again
money is power it also needs to be more
gray it was actually wise thing that
Dasia said and I was like telling her
that I was really upset by something
Beyonce did I felt bad about that
because I still like Beyonce and Dasia
was like you can like her as an artist
and a person and not be okay with
everything that she does it's hard to
because like his one terrible mistake is
a reflection upon everybody who was like
who was a part of the film so like
people weren't choosing not to see it
like me I'm well aware that I am NOT
supporting the cast the crew you know
everyone else and a part of me is like
damn that sucks because like I walk yeah
like I love Gabrielle you know like I'm
sure the crew like worked hard they were
like you know like this was a long
journey
you can always argue that you going to
see the movie doesn't make that much of
a difference but it's just that much
more admirable to take your own personal
stand against it I'm gonna go see the
phone and I can take away from this I
can just learn I'm like this is a
situation I mean I think it's a pretty
clutch situation yeah I think the Birth
of a Nation is gonna be an incredibly
important film and I think that it's
really [ __ ] that it's entrenched in
this yay in this tragedy thank you I'm
gonna Netflix it I love how we act like
that's really sticking it to them I am
I can't separate art from artists yeah I
can't either I think that I'm not gonna
see the movie I can't I'm not gonna
Netflix it I'm not gonna get my money to
it you know that if tomorrow if tomorrow
every guy who was ever charged with
being an [ __ ] and woman people stop
supporting her art you know people would
take a lot more they would think a lot
more before they did stuff I think this
has definitely taught me to look into
people and who they are before I support
them Gracie thanks for joining us today
all right guys so you know what to do
leave your comments below and we'll see
you next week
[Music]